Kakuma refugee camp lies in the Sahel
near the border to South Sudan it's home
to 180,000 refugees some have been here
for 20 years they come from Somalia
eritrea South Sudan Burundi and the
Democratic Republic of Congo Kakuma is
grown to be like a town with businesses
and merchants but refugees aren't
allowed to work they have no prospects
especially young people innocent and
tomba has lived in this mud hut for four
years water is rationed he had to flee
from Goma in the DRC he can't leave the
camp without special permission when he
fled the dr seeing his father a
journalist investigating the smuggling
of resources was targeted by armed
militias many in Kakuma have horrifying
stories to tell I'd said go away when my
father was taken away they came and they
just take him at unknown destination
until now as I'm talking you don't know
where I don't know and my rest of the
family they came at house and they
killed most of the people in the aruba
center students can earn a diploma in
Liberal Studies the center is run by the
Jesuit Refugee service its program is
called higher education at the margins
the students are in contact online with
professors in the US and sit in a
virtual world wide classroom with other
university students right now innocent
is doing research in the library of
Georgetown University in Washington DC
marketing psychology politics and
business management around the
curriculum all of us we are sharing the
same boat online boat so we interact in
groups to from takamatsu from Malawi to
from Yoda and make a team from all the
locations there are similar learning
centers in Thailand Afghanistan Syria
and Chad 2,000 students worldwide have
taken part in the program earning the
equivalent of a bachelor's degree
mounika from Uganda is also studying at
the online University she says that in
the 1990s she was forced by the militias
of the current president to recruit
child soldiers she became an outcast in
her village and had to flee her studies
have revived her optimism Africa has got
so many chances of being employed of
being he lifted up so I'm going to be up
the outside of utah there is no chance
you people you are having high standard
of living and you worked for it it's a
long process if we go there even if I
believe in if you have masters from here
it doesn't make much difference Monica
wants to found a startup company perhaps
in Malawi she can't return to Uganda she
fears she be persecuted by the
government and local rulers Monica and
innocent are two of 20 students getting
their three-year diplomas in Kakuma
their mentored by tutors but their
professors are in the US the leadership
at Regis considered it as a way to serve
people who are in the majendie a
disadvantage Regis goal is to create a
partnership between not only the
us-based students but also students in
this camp and other comes across the
world there's a party in the rupee
Center families and guests have arrived
some of them from the UNHCR the United
Nations refugee agency supports the
program innocent is receiving his
diploma from Regis University as long as
he can't return to his home country he
wants to keep studying he's already made
initial contact with a partner
University in Nairobi refugee camps
offer few prospects but the students at
Kakuma now have an opportunity to
broaden their horizons